Google Insights for Search is a powerful tool...
...to help you analyze the impact of your marketing activities on search interest.
Brand name searches are great indicators of people's ability to recall your brand.
Imagine if you're able to see how searches for your brand changed after running a campaign.
You'd be able to show the impact of your marketing activities on online search...
...and perhaps make a better case for budget in the future.
Here's how to do it with Google Insights for Search.
Let's take the example of Nike's 2006 FIFA World Cup Campaign.
"Joga Bonito" was a highly integrated marketing campaign across media...
...and included a number of television commercials.
Let's look up searches for the campaign, "Joga Bonito" just before and after the World Cup.
Notice how there was an obvious increase in interest levels during the time the campaign ran.
It's apparent that this campaign was effective in triggering more online searches for this term.
Now, let's look at the top related and rising search terms.
Nike's brand tops the list which means that brand association and recall were very high for this particular campaign.
If you're running an integrated marketing campaign like Nike,...
...you can see how effective the campaign was in driving online search interest...
...and how strongly associated it was to the Nike brand.
With Google Insights for Search,...
...you can measure the impact of your marketing activities both offline and online...
...by people's ability to recall and search for your brand.